هناك مقطع فيديو تم إصداره حديثًا يُزعم أنه
يُظهر زعيم فاغنر السابق
لغينيا بريجوسيان وهو يبدو غير مهتم
بسلامته قبل أيام قليلة من
وفاته في وقت سابق من هذا الشهر، ويغطي
فريد بلاتكين، كبير مراسلي CNN الدوليين،
القصة لنا، لذلك فريد، إنه أمر
غريب حقًا سماع هذا الجديد
مقطع من بريجوسيان بعد وفاته،
نعم أنت على حق تمامًا، يوري
ورائع جدًا أيضًا لأنه
يبدو أنه حدد نوعًا ما في الوقت
الذي كان يتحدث فيه عنا أنه كان
في منتصف أغسطس وأين هو يقول
إنه موجود  أفريقيا ولكن كما ذكرت
فهو يتناول أيضًا التكهنات بأنه
قد يُقتل قريبًا. أريد الاستماع
إلى ما قاله باغوجيان في هذا الفيديو
للجميع الذين يناقشون ما إذا كنت
على قيد الحياة أم لا وكيف أفعل ذلك، فهي
حاليًا عطلة نهاية أسبوع في  النصف الثاني
من أغسطس 2023. أنا في أفريقيا، لذا بالنسبة
لأولئك الذين يحبون التكهن بشأن
إقصائي عن حياتي الخاصة وعملي
هناك أو أي شيء آخر، كل شيء على ما يرام في
واقع الأمر،
كل شيء على ما يرام، لقد
قال جايني بريجوسيان في هذا الفيديو بوضوح
بعد يومين، إذا تم تسجيل ذلك بالفعل
في منتصف أغسطس، فلن يكون هناك أي شيء على
ما يرام بالنسبة له، وهو أمر
مثير للاهتمام للغاية لأننا بالطبع نعلم أه
أليكس أنه قبل يومين فقط من
سقوط تلك الطائرة، كان هناك مقطع
فيديو تم إصداره بالفعل بواسطة  فاغنر
يفغيني لغوشين يزعم أنه في أفريقيا
وقال فلاديمير بوتين نفسه أيضًا
أنه عندما أسقطت الطائرة
كان يفغيني بريغوسيان عائداً من
أفريقيا وكذلك يخرج الكرملين الآن
ويقول إنهم
يحققون الآن كما وضعوا احتمالية سقوط
الطائرة  تم إسقاطه
عمدًا بالتأكيد، وهذا لا يشكل
مفاجأة لكثير من الناس،
والشيء الآخر الذي حدث أيضًا اليوم هو أن أحد
كبار قادة فاغنر الآخرين تم
دفنه أيضًا، وكان ديمتري أوتكين
الذي كان له بالطبع دور فعال في
تشكيل فاغنر أيضًا.  أعطت
المنظمة اسمه وكان أيضًا
القائد العسكري لتلك المنظمة،
بالإضافة إلى أحد الأشياء التي التقطناها
والتي كانت مثيرة للاهتمام للغاية هو أنه تم
دفنه في
مقبرة تذكارية خارج القداس مباشرةً في
ضاحية تسمى ميتيشي و  لقد حصل على
مرتبة الشرف العسكرية بالطبع على عكس يفغيني
بريغوسيان أليكس